how are you man
i'm cool
do you hear me yeah what do you got for
me tonight nice to meet you rich
i just wanted to ask um some advice yeah
my situation is like this i've been
working in sales for the last 10 years
and 30 right now
and i got laid off from my previous job
in february okay so
i saw as an opportunity to get into
freelancing
i'm freelancing as a voice actor
narrator things like that
i want to ask you if it's good to start
now that i'm 30 or
skipping sales because these last months
i haven't got a pay a paying job still
so
where do you live
argentina and how old are you
30.
okay so you're you're talking about
going back into sales or doing voice
acting precisely okay so
that's not going to get you to
financial freedom and wealth right i
mean if you're talking about building a
business or building something that's
going to make you over a million dollars
a year usd neither of those things will
ever come close
the voice acting is change is exchanging
time for money what do they pay you for
like an hour or do they pay you by the
gig
for voice acting i still haven't had a
paying job
okay so you haven't actually earned any
money at it no i made a few jobs they
were free i got reviews that's what i'm
using to search for paying clients but
why would you why would you do voice
acting for free
i think
it's
better for my time
i mean it's i i'm not working for a
corporation i'm working for myself
that's the the mentality stop stop stop
stop stop stop you're not working for
yourself if you're not getting paid
okay um
not yet at least right but
like you're not getting paid for doing
the work so why are you doing the work
well i'm starting to do the work so
eventually i get clients that pay me
okay so if you're talking about building
a portfolio that's different exactly you
want to build a resume
exactly exactly i need the experience
first so i can go to the client until
this is what i charge for where do you
where do you advert advertise yourself
you're on fiverr are you on you know
some sort of freelancing site i'm trying
to avoid fiverr i'm mostly doing
instagram twitter
and
i i contact the people ahead or facebook
for example read it they ask for someone
to make a job i contact them okay so let
me ask you so
so if you have a paying job how much
does it pay you
uh
i was told i should charge around three
hundred four hundred dollars and how
long is it okay and how long does it
take you to make that
voice if it's a simple job let's say a
page with dialogues
i can do it two or three days
dude 300 over three days
that's [ __ ] that that [ __ ] that's a
hundred dollars a day
look
i'm sorry
here in argentina i mean 400 dollars is
three times the basis
got it got it got it but i mean you're
still thinking too small
right if you're talking about making a
hundred dollars a day and being happy
with that that's thinking too small
right the entire point of my course and
it's probably out of your price range
you know based on your scenario that
you're right now but the entire point of
the course is to get your head wrapped
around building an easy lucrative and
fun business that's highly profitable
that doesn't you know create havoc in
your life that makes you money that
offers you financial freedom the ability
to maneuver work anywhere in the world
those are the sorts of things that i
spent a lot of time at and you're
talking about making 100 a day that's
way too small thinking right i'm just
being honest with you i mean like
i know a guy that lives in argentina
that does um
he does uh well he has a youtube channel
and also does music and he teaches
people how to play jazz and he does you
know duets with him all sort of stuff
like that
he probably makes that in like 15
minutes
right
just just because the way that he's just
because of the way that he structured
his business now again you know when you
raise your standards and when you hold
yourself to a higher
um minimum line you know like in the
sand if you will again raising your
standards so when you raise your
standards then you're going to do better
and there's going to be people that
you're going to have to leave behind i
mean there's probably a lot of people
around you that are okay with making 100
a day
and if you know if you set a goal of
making a thousand dollars a day
then you're not going to be hanging out
with a hundred dollar a day crowd or the
50 a day crowd right that's why i'm
saying like i want you to think bigger
right like you're thinking too small
news flash we're all going to die
okay
what happens after we die we don't know
who cares it doesn't matter that's not
it for debate right now but what's
factual and true is we're all going to
die so why would you spend time right
now working working you know with the
goal of making a hundred dollars a day
when your goal should be much bigger
so what i'm inviting you to do matthias
is to think bigger you know think
think outside of the box like
one of the modules
in the mindset component i talk
specifically about how great
entrepreneurs think and they don't color
within lines they don't think you know
about you know conventional ways of
doing things
there's in the in the box thinking
there's outside of the box thinking and
then there's guys like steve jobs that
didn't even see the box
right elon musk is another good example
of that right so
the most successful ones the ones that
build the most impactful businesses the
ones that have the most freedom the ones
that make the most money
they're
they don't even recognize the box
anymore but you're still thinking inside
the box you're thinking too small it's
like you know if i exchange some time
and i do this for this gig i'll get 300
and it'll take me three days to do the
auto audio recording sort of thing
it's it's too small thinking man
it's too small
i'm just being honest with you
no okay i i appreciate it i i just
wanted to know how i get from where i am
to that place think bigger
think
think a lot bigger i mean look you're
thinking anyway think bigger
um
do you have um
can you read english well like you're
able to read it
um start i usually usually i pronounce
it better now i'm a little anxious for
being like no i just want to make sure
that you're like you know fluent and
like you know you don't have a problem
reading english books so i would read
books like um richard look
better yet in all of my recent videos if
you go to the top there's an amazon link
for my recommended book list um go to
that link and then select the business
books
and for like 10 bucks
i've got
you know for each books they cost about
10 bucks on kindle or less or you can
get an audio book but you know for
around 10 bucks you can get some really
good books you don't have to buy my
course for a thousand bucks but get some
really good books to at least start on
uh studying excellence study guys like
elon musk study guys like um richard
branson study guys like steve jobs and
see how they think when it comes to
putting things together because right
now you're not even close to playing to
win like you're just playing not to lose
like you just want to make sure you have
rent and food in the fridge and i
understand right because when you're not
working you have to have an income but
again we're all going to die there's
only so much time left in our lives
so
why are you thinking so small so again
what i'm encouraging you to do and what
i'm
asking you to do in fact is think a lot
bigger when it comes to starting a
business
thank you very much you're welcome hey
guys i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you